the champions of england parading their
victory through the streets of
manchester basking in glory city's
players were riding high among their
fans but the behaviour of a small
minority of supporters at yesterday's
game threatened to overshadow the
celebrations at the final whistle
thousands of city fans flooded the pitch
delirious after that remarkable late
comeback but things turned ugly when
aston villa's goalkeeper robin olson was
assaulted
you can see him holding his head after
the attack
it's not on it's not acceptable it
doesn't reflect manchester city it
doesn't reflect football supporters in
general irrespective of who you support
kevin parker is the general secretary
for the side's official fan club because
of celebration and exuberance and all
that that they do come on to the pitch
we have to educate them that come on and
enjoy yourselves
and do not be an absolute idiot because
it spoils it for everybody
rightly so there is so much joy here as
huge crowds have flocked into town to
see the premier league champions but the
scenes after yesterday's game follow a
week of harmful behavior from some fans
sheffield united captain billy sharp
needed stitches after he was head-butted
by a nottingham forest supporter
following a play-off semi-final
if they're celebrating it's not a
problem you know you're jubilant you're
excited what i cannot understand is if
your t especially if your team has won
why you would want to go and go the
opposition pitch invasions aren't
allowed but they aren't new however the
fa has said they're concerned about the
rise in anti-social behavior but what
are the solutions
when we have more policing more studying
sniffer dogs at every corner it creates
tension it creates a climate of
suspicion and maybe paranoia so actually
we need to to flip it on its head
instead of clamping down really hard and
and getting more aggressive police
tactics we actually want police and
security forces to be working with the
fans
many seem to agree that a return to
perimeter fencing would be a potentially
dangerous way to deal with the problem
but while some worry about a new wave of
hooliganism across the game city
supporters are relishing retaining the
title becky kotchel sky news manchester